les journalistes de l'est ont le droit
de pénétrer mais les journalistes
occidentaux non il leur reste le loisir
de battre la semelle par -20° une
censure stricte de l'information voilà à
quoi étaient confrontés les médias
occidentaux en allemagne de l'est en
pleine occupation soviétique
deux ans après l'érection du mur de
berlin la dictature communiste y était
alors bien installés seuls les grands
événements du parti permettait aux
journalistes étrangers d'entrer en rvr
c'était donc la semaine dernière fait à
berlin est en l'honneur du congrès du
parti et nous en avons profité pour y
faire ce reportage qui en d'autres temps
nous aurait été interdit des images
interdite sans autorisation sous peine
de prison ou pire de subir les poudres
de la stasi la police d'état difficile
alors dans ces conditions de recueillir
des témoignages d'allemands de l'être en
1972 le journaliste français jean pierre
elkabbach avait trouvé la parade
interviewé à l'ouest des évadés de la r
d
ils ont beaucoup construit mais il
manque la couleur ce traître écrit quand
on passe dans le rues les maisons sont
construites sur une forme simple et
uniforme
une image austère que le gouvernement de
l'est souhaitait comme et dès le début
des années 70 pour vanter le mode de vie
en rda les autorités autorisent est
ponctuellement certains médias
occidentaux à venir filmer le quotidien
des familles mais pas n'importe quelle
famille exemple en 1974
fischer c'est le nom de cette famille de
zeitz que nous avons regardé vivre une
famille standard de rda wind une famille
choisie pour nous par les autorités des
personnes très bien choisi pour porter
la parole du gouvernement est encensé le
quotidien à l'aise que je suis non
seulement heureux de faire mon travail
et d'exercer cette responsabilité
syndicale
je suis aussi très heureux de pouvoir
vivre dans cet état de rda
cinq ans plus tard même discours pour
cette berlinoise hors de question de
quitter l'est
j'étais heureuse à berlin oui je suis
rollin est oui à berlin est oui c'est
bon aussi pour échapper au contrôle des
autorités et certains journalistes
français osait prendre des risques en
1987 pour être libre et ramener les
images qu'il voulait ce journaliste de
fr3 s'était fait passer pour un touriste
je ne craignais pas pour ma sécurité
mais pour mai mais pour ma liberté je
fais n'est simplement pour la cassette
qu'on était susceptible de nous retirer
ce qui fait que j'avais essayé d'éviter
de montrer j'étais journaliste
effectivement n'ayant rien qui le
prouvaient sur moi mais surtout en
évitant de filmer les sujets sensibles
notamment les forces de l'ordre une
censure de l'information en allemagne de
l'est qui prendra fin le 9 novembre 1989
le jour de la chute du mur de la route
[Musique]